Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Abend. Ich heiße Mustafa Gönes. Ich bin zuständige Arzt in der Notaufnahme für Sie.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anonysegespräch führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Gerne. Bitte schön.
Zuerst soll ich Ihre Personaldaten dokumentieren. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Otto Werner.
Otto mit Doppelte.
Jawohl.
Ihre Nachname könnten Sie noch einmal buchten.
Werner.
Wie?
E-Mail hat Nordpol E-Mail Richard.
Herr Werner. Okay. Vielen Dank für Ihre Geduld.
Wie alt sind Sie denn?
Ich bin 75 Jahre alt.
75.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 75 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie denn?
75.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. 1. 1944.
44.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 71 groß.
Darf ich fragen, wie viel Sie aktuell wiegen?
Ungefähr 92 Kilogramm.
92.
Wie lange sind Sie?
Gut, Herr Werner.
Was bedingt du uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe seit ca. 1 Jahr immer wieder erhrende Schmerzen in meinem
rechten Knie.
Die bei Belastung auftreten.
Wenn ich lange Strecke laufe, wenn ich treppen laufe, habe ich
Schmerzen bei Belastung.
Wenn die Schmerzen sehr stark sind, treten die Schmerzen
auch in Nachts in Ruhe auf.
Okay.
Nur in rechten Knie haben Sie Schmerzen.
Jawohl.
In anderen Körperteilen oder anderen Gelenken haben Sie
keine Schmerzen oder?
Nein, habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Beim Treppensteigen haben Sie diese Beschwerden.
Genau, habe ich Schmerzen stärken.
Schmerzen ist nicht stärker.
Schmerzen, Schmerzen sich verstärkt,
meinen Sie.
Ja, die verstärken sich.
Schmerzen, die sich verstärken.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Nachts in der Ruhe habe ich auch Schmerzen manchmal.
Also wenn es sehr schlimm ist.
Okay.
Also nicht immer.
Ich habe nicht durchgehende Schmerzen seit einem Jahr,
sondern immer wiederkehrende Schmerzen.
Okay.
Verstehe ich.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Es ist sehr unangenehm für Sie, Herr Renner.
Ich muss nicht nur diese Anamnesegespräch führen,
sondern auch dokumentieren.
Ich bitte Sie ein bisschen Geduld.
Okay.
Ja, muss ich poppeln.
Vielen Dank.
Das ist sehr wichtig,
dann wichtige Diagnose zu festzustellen.
Okay.
Herr Renner,
wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala
von ein bis zehn vorbei,
ein sehr leichter und sehr unerträgliche Schmerzen spricht?
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, und zwar, ich würde sagen,
fünf.
Also wenn ich die Schmerzen habe,
dann sind die fünf.
Manchmal habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Aber da sind aktuell die fünf.
Aktuell fünf.
Beim Treppensteigen und beim Belastung haben Sie
fünf.
Okay.
In Ruhe, wie schätzen Sie ein Schmerzen?
Wie die Schmerzen?
Ich würde sagen, nachts, ja,
würde ich auch so fünf sagen.
Also wenn es auch in Ruhe ist, dann mache ich manchmal auf
und muss ein Kissen zwischen meinen Beinen tun.
Also würde ich auch sagen, schön.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas probiert,
zum Beispiel Wärmefläche
oder eine Medikamente?
Kühlen hat mir geholfen.
Ich nehme auch manchmal Kühlen
oder ich nehme ab und zu mal auch ein Medikament ein.
Okay. Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie bei Bedarf ein?
Im Profi 600 Milligramm.
600 Milligramm.
Und hat sich immer ein bisschen geholfen
in meinem Belastung?
Ja.
Wenn ich im Profi einnehme,
dann findet es meine Schmerzen.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Wie würden Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Eher stechend, dumpfen Sie,
handbrochend?
Ja, ich würde sagen,
wenn ich nicht beschreiben, so ein Druckgefühl würde ich sagen.
Ich habe im Knie so ein,
also wenn die Schmerzen da sind,
die sind manchmal stechend und manchmal so ein Druckgefühl.
Insbesondere wenn mein Knie dick wird.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Stechende und Druckgefühl.
Herr Werner,
haben Sie
eine Bewegung,
einen Schmerzbemerkung?
Ja, also ich kann mein Knie nicht,
wenn ich das Knie habe,
dann kann ich mein Knie nicht beugen,
maximal beugen, ich kann die nur so bis 90 Grad beugen, mehr nicht.
Nicht beugen, okay.
Nicht beugen, aber nicht richtig komplett beugen,
wie mein Link ist, wie kann ich nicht beugen.
Haben Sie auch Überwarmung
und Rötung bemerkt?
Rötung nicht, aber Überwärmung,
das ist jetzt nicht so ganz warm,
aber es ist wärmer als mein linkes Knie.
Könnten Sie nochmal sagen?
Also mein Rettknie ist geschwollen,
dick
und wärme dann drin.
Also an meinem Knie finde ich auch
leichte Wärme, also nicht richtig rot
und bochend Schmerz.
Vielleicht wärme es schon, also ein bisschen wärmer als mein linkes Knie.
Ah, okay, als linkes Knie, okay.
In der Ruhe,
oder wenn Sie
keine Schmerzen haben,
haben Sie
eine Schwellung bemerkt?
Ja, also mein Knie ist dick, ja.
Ja, immer.
Die letzten Monate,
drei Monate ist immer dick, aber nicht immer sehr dick.
Nur wenn es der März da ist, wird es dicker
und manchmal, wo ich keine Schmerzen habe,
wird es weniger dick, aber immer noch dick.
Haben Sie eine blaue Flecke bemerkt?
Betroffenen, körperteile?
Nein, nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Nein, fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Ich hab kein Fieber.
Leiden Sie unter Stärkfurst oder Nachschweiß?
Nein.
Okay, gut.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Sturrgang
oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nee, hab ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Herzrasen oder Herzsturpen oder Gusten bemerkt?
Nein, nicht, dass ich das nicht wüsste.
Okay.
Herr Werner,
haben Sie
eine unterchenkel oder oberchenkel
Missempfindung, meine ich,
einen Krippen oder am Eisenlauch bemerkt?
Nein.
Ich habe das nicht gewählt.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch
Entschuldigung,
Herr Werner, haben Sie
haben Sie Taubheitsgefühl bemerkt?
Kein Taubheitsgefühl.
Okay, gut.
Möchten Sie noch sonst
noch etwas hinzufügen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ich habe auch jetzt nicht Kraftverlust,
habe ich auch nicht.
Ansonsten habe ich halt nur
Lastungsabhängig-Schmerzen.
Nein, also nichts Besonderes.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter
Chronische für Erkrankungen,
so wie
Bluthochdruck oder
Schiebdruck,
oder so wie
Bluthochdruck,
Bluthochdruck oder Schiebdruck,
unter Funktionen.
Nein, also ich nehme zwei Medikamente ein,
regelmäßig. Das eine ist Ramipril,
10 Milligramm, die nämlich morgens
einem leicht erhöhten Bluthochdruck.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig morgens,
oder? Ja, genau.
Und zweite? Das zweite ist Simpastatin,
nehm ich 20 Milligramm abends eine Tablette ein.
Okay.
Nehmen noch einen Medikament ein,
ich nehme noch Ass 101.
Ass 101.
Auch einmal abends.
Das hat mein Haus weggegeben, weil ich
ein höherem Alter bin, soll ich als Vorsichtsmaster
nehmen, also nicht, weil ich irgendwie eine Erkrankung hatte oder so.
Also, deswegen leiden Sie an Bluthochdruck, oder?
Das weiß ich nicht, also ich sollte es halt
einnehmen, weil ich älter geworden bin
und das wäre sicher besser, hat er gesagt.
Ist das selber Entscheidung?
Vom Hausarzt.
Ah, Hausarzt, okay.
Er hat gesagt, soll Sicherheitshalbermaß 100 nehmen.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
Was für eine Erkrankung?
Haben Sie keine bestimmte Vorerkrankungen? Nein.
Hat er gesagt, wie Herzinfarkt oder so,
vielleicht ist es deswegen, weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Okay, gut. Wann war der Liste-Kontrol
im Hausarzt?
Bis auf ein Monat.
Ein Monat.
Was, alles in Ordnung?
Ja, der hatte vorab genommen, der hat EKG gemacht,
meine Lunge abgehört, war alles okay,
also er hat mir jetzt nichts gesagt.
Okay, gut.
Ich würde sonst noch etwas nachfragen,
Herr Werner.
Wie,
wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ein Appetit ist, ich denke normal, gut.
Sind Sie gerne Fleisch,
oder Fleischweiche?
Schmack,
vielleicht jetzt ist auch das Saison da, Grillen
und so weiter, also Scherzen.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden, Herr Werner?
Ja, ich bin schon mal operiert worden,
schon einmal operiert worden, Herr Werner.
Jawohl, an meinem rechten Knie wurde ich operiert,
einmal vor 30 Jahren.
Da hatte ich ein Schienbeinkopfbruch gehabt,
die wurde mit Platte und Schraube versorgt.
Das war danach alles,
und vor zehn Jahren wurde ich atroskopiert
an meinem rechten Knie.
Vor 30 Jahren haben Sie gesagt.
Vor 30 Jahren hatte ich einen Unfall gehabt.
Ein Fahrradunfall.
Ja.
Und schnell wurden Sie operiert.
Genau, also man hat, ich war, hatten Unfall gehabt,
vor 30 Jahren, und dann war ich im Krankenhaus,
und im Krankenhaus haben die gesehen, das ist gebrochen,
und das haben wir dann operiert.
Gebrochene Knochen.
Am Unterschenkel.
Schienbeinkopfbruch.
Schienbein, okay.
Die wurde mit Platte und Schrauben operiert.
Platte und Schrauben operiert.
Ansonsten hat er sich keine Operation.
In meiner Kindheit hatte ich auch zwei Operationen gehabt.
Einmal einen Schraub,
dann hatte ich auch zwei Operationen gehabt.
Einmal wurde mein Blindam entfernt, da war ich 15 Jahre alt.
Einmal wurde meine Mandeln entfernt,
da war ich sieben Jahre alt.
Zehn Jahre alt.
Sieben.
Mandeloperation mit sieben,
Blindam über 15 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Was war das für ein OP-Komplication los?
Bei der Blindam-Operation,
wenn mein Blindam geplatzt war,
wurde Antibiotika gegeben,
und damals hatte ich allergisch reagiert.
Aber es wurde dann behandelt,
und seitdem darf ich auch keinen Antibiotika Benizilien nehmen.
Okay.
Das heißt, haben Sie Benizilien allergisch?
Jawohl.
Wie war das?
Damals hatte ich dann ein Problem mit Atem.
Ich konnte nicht richtig atmen.
Mein Hals war geschworen.
Okay, richtig.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Noch nie, meine ich, oder?
Nein, ich hatte nie geraucht.
Nehmen Sie gelegentlich oder regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ich würde sagen, nicht viel.
Ich trinke jeden Abend ein Glas Wein zu meinem Essenabendessen.
Ein Glas Wein, war.
Ja, ein bisschen Wein.
Zum Essen ist immer schön.
Ich genieße es.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Nehmen Sie bitte die folgende Frage persönlich.
Nein, nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, kurz und am Nicht.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie Drogen geschrieben wird.
Super.
Leben Ihrer Erden noch, Herr Werner?
Nein, die leben nicht mehr.
Woran sind Sie?
Ich bin noch nicht mehr.
Woran sind Sie gestorben?
Herr sich an Beileid.
Mein Vater, der war mit 80 Jahren verstorben,
an Herzinfarkt.
Okay.
Meine Mutter ist verstorben an einem Magentugmur.
Okay, ja, verstehe ich.
Leiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe es auch.
Wie ist es mit den Erkrankungen?
Ich weiß nur, dass mein Vater
eine Beipassopie hatte
und Bluthochdruck hatte.
Okay, ja.
Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter hatte Insulin gespritzt.
Wie nennt man das Diabetes?
Ja, die war auch übergewichtig gewesen.
Herr Werner, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe ein Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Ich weiß, dass er eine Medikamente nimmt.
Weswegen, warum, genau, weiß ich nicht.
Aber wegen der Schildrüse.
Und er hat auch eine Bluthochdruckerkrankung.
Bluthochdruck.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Werner?
Das ist vorbei.
Ich bin Rentner.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet, habe zwei Kinder.
Meine Kinder sind gesund, Gott sei Dank.
Oh, Gott sei Dank.
Okay, wir sind fast fertig, Herr Werner.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Was habe ich denn, Herr Doktor?
Es ist so für mich, ich kann noch nicht sagen,
was Sie haben, Herr Werner.
Wir haben ein paar Untersuchungen führen.
In der Klinikum.
Wir arbeiten ja als
großes Erfahrenstem.
Nach der Untersuchung,
sobald wir alle Ergebnisse vorlegen haben,
werde ich Sie informieren,
schrittverschuld informieren, was Sie genau haben.
Ich bitte Sie ein bisschen geduld.
Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorge.
Sie sind in den guten Enden.
Dankeschön.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Ja.
Seit wann wegen Sie über 90 kg
sind Sie in der Klinikum?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Seit wann?
Seit einigen Jahren, ich weiß nicht genau,
über 10 Jahren bestimmt.
Ich bin immer um die 90 kg, manchmal 92, manchmal 93,
aber seit 10 Jahren würde ich sagen, um die 90 kg.
Aktuell bin ich 92 kg.
Okay, danke schön.
Danke.
Ich habe gesagt, 75 Jahre alt und geboren am Geboren,
erst 1945.
Jawoll.
Aber...
Oder habe ich falsch gesagt?
Ja.
Ach so, nicht 49 geboren.
Ja, 49.
Danke schön, ich habe da einen Fehler gesagt.
Ich wollte prüfen, ob Sie aufpassen.
Können wir erst das Gespräch anfangen, Herr Jan?
Ein paar Minuten bitte.
Also ich habe eine Frage.
Ja bitte.
Wieso hatten Sie eine Artroskopie vor zehn Jahren?
Damals hatte ich Schmerzen im Knie und die haben gesagt,
dass der Miniskus irgendwie studiert werde und dann haben die operiert
und ein Teil des Miniskus haben die rausgenommen.
Ja, das ist die selbe Knie, ja?
Ja, genau.
Als vor 30 Jahren hatte ich ein Schiembahn-Kopfbruch
und vor zehn Jahren hatte ich dann eine Artroskopie
und jetzt seit einem Jahr habe ich immer wieder kerrende Schmerzen.
Okay, danke.
Sind Sie alle Kinderkrankheiten, auch Corona geimpft?
Ja, also die Kinderkrankheiten wurden geimpft,
laut meiner Eltern, so genau weiß ich das nicht,
aber ich denke schon, was man so gemacht hat, weiß ich genau nicht,
aber meine Eltern, meine Mutter, sagte mir,
ja, du hast die Impfung alle hinter sich
und Corona-Impfung hatte ich auch gehabt,
vor ein paar Jahren.
Ich bin dreifach geimpft.
Haben Sie Schmerzen in den Wirbelsäule
und auch Morgensteifigkeit?
Also Morgensteifigkeit vielleicht an meinem Knie,
aber nicht an der Wirbelsäule,
in der Wirbelsäule habe ich nicht wirklich Schmerzen.
Haben Sie sich in der letzten Zeit verletzt
oder runtergefallen?
Ne, die letzte Zeit nichts.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Oh, nee, Sport treibe ich habe ich jahrelang nicht mehr gemacht.
Früher habe ich auch Fußball gespielt, aber ab meinem 16. Lebst,
ja, also seit 15 Jahren mache ich kein Sport mehr.
Ich fahre vielleicht ab und zu mal Fahrrad,
also nicht regelmäßig.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie schon einmal Augenentzündung gehabt?
Augenentzündung?
Ja.
Irgendwann kann sein, dass ich mal das gehabt habe,
aber ich kann mich nicht dran erinnern.
Ich glaube nicht.
Hat Ihnen unter den Durchfall?
Durchfall, nein, aktuell nicht.
Danke.
In meinem Leben hatte ich schon mal Durchfall gehabt,
aber jetzt aktuell nicht, in der letzten Zeit.
Nicht.
Herr Sonne.
Schönen guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Haben Sie eine neue Zeit für mich?
Ich habe eine neue Patiente vorzustellen.
Ja, ich bin hier, schieß mal los.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Otto Werner, 75-jährige Patiente,
stellte sich bei uns in der Notaufnahme
wegen seit ungefähr einem Jahr
rechten Königsmärzchen vor.
Die Schmerzen treten beim Belastung
oder Treppensteigen auf.
Auf der Schmerzgala liegt
die Schmerzen bei 5 von 10.
Dagegen hat er Kühlung probiert
und auch nehme er bei Bedarf
überpräfen 600 mg ein.
Die beide haben ihm geholfen.
Die Schmerzen sind erstens
stechend und durkend.
Darüber hinaus klagte er
leichter rechten Knie über Warmung,
ödeme, klagte über Warmung und ödeme.
Er hatte keine Kraftlosigkeit.
Ansonsten war er unaufwändig.
Er wusste keine Vorerkrankungen.
Er nahm sich gerne mit 10 mg morgens.
Er war 20 mg abends.
Er ist 100 mg abends ein.
Alle Medikamente wurden beim Hausarzt geschrieben.
Deswegen werde ich beim Hausarzt nachfragen,
warum er diese Medikamente nimmt.
Er hat nicht gesagt, warum er wegen Ramaprile einen Namen hat.
Vor Operationen hatte er in der Kindheit Appendectomy und Tonzerectomy.
Vor 30 Jahren wegen des Fahrradunfalls
wurde die Thibia-Halsfraktur behandelt.
Die Thibia-Kopffraktur wurde mit einer Plattenostiösyntese versorgt.
Die Thibia-Halsfraktur wurde mit einer Plattenostiösyntese versorgt.
Der Patient sagt, es sei Platten und Schrauben,
aber man sagt, es sei Platten und Schrauben,
sondern eine Platte gehört immer eine Schraube dazu.
Deswegen sagt man Plattenostiösyntese versorgt.
Er ist nicht rauchig.
Trinke, Abends, Einglass, Wein.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er ist in der Familienanwesen,
er ist im Vater an die Myokarte verstorben
und ihre Mutter an die Magenkarsen verstorben.
Er hat einen Bruder, er leidet Hypothyriose
und Arteriellaibatoni.
Sie haben andere Vorerkampfungen gefragt.
Wenn die Oberarzt Fragen hatte, könnte ich antworten.
Deswegen alle Informationen dieser Sendung.
Er ist aktuell Sendner,
aber ich habe vorher vergessen, was er früher gemacht hat.
Er ist verheiratet und hat zwei gesunde Erwachsene.
Er hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Man kann vielleicht sagen, er hat zwei gesunde erwachsene Kinder. Erwachsene,
wortende Kinder kann man auch sagen, aber zwei Kinder kann man auch sagen.
Er hat eine Präsentiealergie, die mit Dysne und Angiödeme äußert.
Ja, eigentlich das war es.
Okay, dann hat, was denken Sie, was der Patient hat? Was ist Ihre Verdachtstdiagnose?
Er ist übergewichtig, also eine Depositustand.
Im Großen und Ganzen denke ich an eine Gonardrose.
Kennen Sie so die grobe Einteilung von der Gonardrose?
Den Begriff primäre und sekundäre Gonardrose?
Ich glaube, eine sekundäre Verletzung nach der A in der OP.
Er hatte eine Verletzung in der Vergangenheit gehabt und deswegen geht man davon aus,
dass er eine sekundäre Gonardrose haben könnte.
Weil er aktuell mit Schmerzen da ist, kann man noch ein bisschen detaillierter sagen,
dass er eine aktivierte sekundäre Gonardrose hat.
Okay.
Eine aktivierte, kündige, aktivierte.
Das Knie ist geschwollend, vielleicht die Wärme, Schmerzen bei Belastung.
Deswegen kann man auch sagen, der hat dann eine aktivierte sekundäre Gonardrose, könnte er haben.
Das ist die Verdachtstdiagnose. Was denken Sie als Alternativen?
Die Nationaldiagnostik kommen auch eine septische Arthritis.
Ja.
Sie haben ja gefragt, der hat keinen Fieber.
Ist es okay, dass er keinen Fieber hat, wenn er eine septische Arthritis hat?
Es könnte sein, ein febrile Körpertemperatur.
Das könnte schon sein.
Bei älteren Menschen ist es nicht immer so, dass immer ein Fieberzustand kommen könnte.
Also ja, es könnte ein septische Arthritis oder ein MPM sein.
Was könnte es noch sein?
Es könnte auch ein Koaligenose oder Wasco-Litinsen sein.
Vorhin haben Sie etwas gefragt, den Patienten.
Sie haben gesagt, es ist eher gerne viel Fleisch.
Ja, ein hyperurikemi Arthritis könnte sein.
Ein akuter Gichtanfall, zum Beispiel, könnte es auch sein.
Oder, was kann es auch noch sein?
Viel im Knie, da gibt es eine Arthose.
Was gibt es meistens noch?
Ein Knie-Feschlus.
Ja, noch einfacher.
Ein Miscus-Verletzung.
Genau.
Das ist ein Erdbeutel.
Das ist eher traumatisch.
Aber ein Miscus-Risb könnte auch eine Lesion sein.
Vor zehn Jahren hatte ich eine Atroskopie.
Ein Erdbeutel.
Das könnte noch mehr kaputt gegangen sein.
Das reicht auch.
Wie gehen Sie vor?
Jetzt haben Sie eine Verdachtsterechnose.
Ja.
Ich würde zuerst eine verpägliche Untersuchung machen.
Bei der Inspektion achte ich eine Überwärmung und Erdthema an der rechten Knie.
Und die Kalpation, ob ich die Druckhafte ödee, oder nicht, habe ich eine Druckpare ödee, oder nicht.
Es hört sich immer besser an, wenn man sagt, ich mache nicht eine körperliche Untersuchung, sondern ich mache immer eine ausführliche körperliche Untersuchung.
Ja, ausführliche körperliche Untersuchung.
Das mache ich mit einer Motoreg-Sensibilität und Durchblutung.
Genau, körperliche Untersuchung bezüglich der Motoreg, der Sensibilität und der Durchblutung.
Sie haben das Knie untersucht.
Wie gehen Sie voran?
Als Labor werde ich ein kleines Blutbild und ein Sinduk-Parameter, wie PSG, Lukasüden und CRP.
Ich möchte auch eine Rheuma-Faktor feststellen, eine Motoreg-Athritis auszuschließen.
Also in der Notfallaufnahme würde man das nicht machen, das würde man später empfehlen, wenn man vieles gemacht hat.
Als zweitln, erstes nicht, aber die Harnsäure könnte man ja bestimmen, weil er vielleicht einen Gehwahl haben könnte.
Ja, genau, eine Harnsäure spielt Bestimmung.
Was würden Sie dann auch machen?
Als Labordiagnostik werde ich einen Röntgenaufnahme in rechten Knies, weil ich ihn entfällen lassen.
Was könnte man dort feststellen, was sehen Sie im Röntgenbild?
Anders sagen Sie, was kann man im Röntgen gut darstellen?
Ja, wir können die Gelenkspaltung beurteilen, Osterofen und den Vergleichen der anderen Knien,
die gelenkfähig verminderte Gelenkspalt und die obaflechtliche Regulationen und Osterofen oder so können wir beurteilen.
Man kann eine Degeneration des Kniegelenkes beurteilen, wie zum Beispiel Osterofen-Anbauten,
Spaltverschmielerung oder Kontralisglerisierung könnte man sehen, als Zeitpunkt Natrose.
Oder man kann eine Bruch, eine Fraktur, oder man könnte, kann man den Menyskus darstellen?
Wir können die Menyskus nicht beurteilen in der Röntgenaufnahme, wir müssen eine weitere Wildgebung veranlassen.
Welche Aufnahme gibt es in diesem Verfahren, würden Sie veranlassen?
Ich würde gerne einen MRT in rechten Knien veranlassen.
Okay, richtig. Also wenn Sie aber jetzt ein Röntgenbild sehen, der kein Gelenkspalt mehr hat, sozusagen und Osterofen hat, würden Sie trotzdem ein MRT veranlassen?
Ja, natürlich. Können wir die Bänderis oder Menyskus-Teile?
Aber bei einer fortgeschrittenen Arthrose, da ist der Menyskus bestimmt kaputt, sozusagen.
Also wenn der Gelenkspalt nicht mehr da ist, nicht mehr da ist, dann braucht man nicht unbedingt ein MRT, das Knies so ganz verschliessen.
Aber man kann MRT sehen, zum Beispiel die Bänder, man kann auch sehen, ob da ein Knochen-Ödem ist, das auch schon.
Ein Knochen-Ödem, oder muskulär-Ödem, oder weitere.
Können wir teilweise Tab oder Total Tab beurteilen? Ist das uns helfen?
Das ist ja erst später mit Tab oder nicht und so weiter. Bei einer fortgeschrittenen Arthrose, was ein Röntgen ein sehr degenerativer Knie ist, dann braucht man keine MRT, um zu entscheiden, ob der Knie-Tab braucht oder nicht.
Dafür ist die Klinik wichtig. Wenn man konservativ therapiert, würden Sie gleich sagen, was.
Und wenn das alles nicht hilft, dann kann man an einer Knie-Tab denken.
Wie gehen Sie voran? Sie sehen ein Knie, der hat eine aktivierte, sekundäre mediale Gonnathrose zum Beispiel.
Der hat schwarke Schmerzen. Was empfehlen Sie?
Jetzt haben Sie die Diagnose, das Sie vorher gedacht haben, das hat sich bestätigt.
Was kann man jetzt machen?
Ich würde so erst eine Analgesie empfehlen.
Wenn die Erzündung der Pyramide erhöht ist, empfehle ich vielleicht eine Antibiotika.
Wenn Sie an eine Infektion denken, was sollte man vor einer Antibiotika-Gabe idealerweise machen?
Beim Ultraschall können wir eine Funktion machen und Bluterguss oder Gelenkerguss aspirieren.
Und dann eine Kultur oder eine Miproskopische.
Die Funktion würden Sie dann zur Biologie schicken.
Jetzt fällt mir selber nicht ein.
An Bakterielle Stimmung.
Sie haben gesagt, kühlen, schonen.
Ich würde sagen, Petru sagen, weil dann Muskelatur abbauen, aber schonen.
Dass er jetzt nicht lange weggeläuft und ein bisschen Ruhe hat.
Petru heißt dann, dass der Patient den Bett bleibt und ein Toilettenstuhl nimmt anhand.
Der geht nicht zur Toilette, der geht nichts machen.
Ich würde generell sagen, eine Schonung, eine Kühlung und Schmerztherapie.
Annel, Sie, was würden Sie geben?
Beim Schmerztherapie empfehle ich einen NSRA, nicht steroidale Antiräume.
Dann empfehle ich eine Magenschutz wegen der Nebenwirkungen.
Wenn man als Schmerztherapie ein geschwollenes Knie hat,
dann könnte man das auch machen, weil man einen deutlicher Kniegelang hat.
Wir müssen aspirieren.
Wenn Sie aspirieren, dann tun Sie den Druck wegnehmen.
Wenn man das mit einem anderen Medikament rein geht, dann ist das nicht so.
Proflaktische Antibiotika, meine Sie.
Nein, ich denke, wenn ich aspiriere, dann denke ich,
dass es eine klare bernsteinfarbige Flüssigkeit ist.
Ich denke nicht direkt an eine Antibiotika,
sondern wenn die Entzündung im Knie sehr stark ist, dann läuft diese Flüssigkeit wieder nach.
Es fühlt sich wieder mit Wasser.
Also muss ich die Entzündung wegnehmen.
Also kann ich ein Medikament reingeben, damit die Entzündung schnell ...
Ein Metilprednisolone oder so, meine Sie.
Kristallin-Kortison, z.B. Triamtsinolone oder Lipotalone.
Also ein Cortison rein.
Abbaute, damit es sich nicht wieder mit Flüssigkeit fühlt.
Ja, okay.
So mache ich das.
Ja, verstehe ich Herr Obas.
Sie haben recht, natürlich.
Sonst nach zwei, drei Tagen wird es wieder voll.
Sie geben NSR, kühlung, Schonung.
Und was würden Sie noch empfehlen?
Ja, das nicht jetzt.
Dieses Jahr empfehle ich eine Operation nach der orthophilischen Konzül.
Wir wollen noch zurückgehen.
Also man gibt Analgetika an die inflammatory Analgetika
oder noch zusätzlich andere Analgetikas dazu.
Aber was nicht ärztlich ist, was würden Sie noch verordnen zusätzlich?
Zusätzlich ein ...
Damit es zu einer besseren Ablauf der Gelenkbewegung gibt.
Eine Pythiotherapie, Krankengymnastik.
Krankengymnastik, Pythiotherapie.
Genau.
Was, also man kann eine Pythiotherapie verordnen
oder man kann auf dem Patient auch sagen,
kann zusätzlich Fahrrad fahren,
ist auch eine Krankengymnastik, gute Krankengymnastik.
Weil man das auch folgt und streckt beim Fahrrad fahren.
Oder schwimmen.
So, wenn das alles nicht helfen würde,
was würden Sie empfehlen?
Ja, eine Operation,
eine ...
eine Totalendoprotese oder Partialprotese.
Genau, je nach Röntgen, je nach Röntgen befunden,
könnte man das, wenn er eine mediale Konatrosat macht,
man eine Teilprotese, also eine Schnitzprotese.
Und wenn er eine Pangonatrosat hat,
dann wird man dann eine Knitepine.
Totalendoprotese.
Ja, Knitepine. Total Knitepine.
Nicht Hirn, sondern wir Ärzte, wir empfehlen.
Er muss selber entscheiden.
Ja, natürlich, ja, wir empfehlen.
Wir können zusammen entscheiden mit der Patientin.
Genau, richtig.
Okay.
Gut, von meiner Seite, aber war es das,
haben Sie noch Fragen?
An mich?
Nein, ich habe keine Fragen.
Sie haben alles erklärt.
Gut.
Hat jemand in der Gruppe noch eine Frage?
Ich verstehe nicht.
Sie benutzen Kühlung, neben Kühlung.
Kühlung.
Kühlung, aber anderen Wort, ich weiß nicht.
Schonung.
Was bedeutet Schonung?
S-C-H-O-M-U-N-G.
Schonen heißt, dass man nicht viel belastet,
dass man belastet, aber nicht viel.
Das heißt, Schonen, wie soll ich das umschreiben,
relative Verminderung der Belastung.
Okay, danke.
Schonung.
Was ist die Türkei?
Ich habe das Bild.
Was?
Das Bild, das Bild.
Konservative?
Konservative, das heißt...